foreign
[Music]
good morning everyone thank you for
joining our session building your ml op
strategy for generative AI pretty light
not so dense topic for Wednesday morning
I'm sure my name is Mikhail an outbound
product manager on vertex Ai and later
on stage I'll be joined by Arena our
product manager of our vertex AI
evaluation Services before we jump into
our content I want to run a quick poll
number one if you could raise your hand
if you or someone on your team has
actually built a really exciting
compelling demo with generative AI in
the last few months
a lot of folks more than half the room
and I think we've really seen you know
the pace of hackathons and working
prototypes really increase over the last
few months number two how many of you
have taken said demo into production
a lot less a lot less and number three
last question I promise how many of you
have really spent the last few years
designing thinking about and maybe
rolling out an ml op strategy before
generative AI
okay get him out get him out
so I think really I think we're going to
really tackle
um these questions and really address
two key themes number one and based on
all this this quick poll building is
easy deploying them into a Enterprise
ready production environment is really
really hard and this quote from Chip I
think a lot of us uh really feel the
same way
second is really you know isn't it funny
a lot of you raise your hands for that
last question right as we were getting a
hang of ml Ops personally have my
professional ml engineering
certification proudly in my LinkedIn
profile right as we were getting a hang
of this now we're really you know
introduced to a brand new Mountain of
terms across llm Ops gen AI Ops things
like vector databases prompt engineering
so really we'll touch on the best
practices and really believe that you do
not have to start from scratch
so what's our agenda for today uh we'll
quickly revisit ml Ops from the last few
years we'll share an evolving framework
I highlight evolving we are very early
in this space and I'm excited to have
Arena come on stage and share some of
our new evaluation Services launching
specifically for generative AI use cases
and then we'll end with a recap
so first let's quickly start by
revisiting Emma lops from it from a few
years ago and we'll actually start with
a direct quote from our practitioner's
guide to ml Ops paper from early 2021 ml
Ops is a set of standardized processes
and capabilities for building deploying
and operationalizing ml systems rapidly
and reliably throughout this paper there
are a number of Concepts highlighted
shorter development Cycles to accelerate
time to market Standard governance
processes to manage and monitor models
and really increase reliability
performance and scalability from a first
glance really our hypothesis is that the
objective of ml Ops or generative AI
should remain very similar if not the
same
and fun fact to the authors of this
paper Don and Eric are actually here
somewhere so uh see if you can find them
and maybe pick their brains a little bit
more for the remainder of the conference
so from that starting point we really do
believe that you can start by building
on existing ml Ops foundations and
there's really two big two big Ideas
number one no need to throw away your
existing ml Ops Investments there is a
path to extend mlaps foundations from
yesterday's AI
what we're going to refer to today as
predictive AI to today's generative AI a
lot of the Core Concepts we really feel
have a lot of similar characteristics
managing and evaluating models
orchestrating pipelines evaluating and
monitoring models in a systematic way
however I don't think we you know we
need to acknowledge that generative AI
does introduce a lot of unique
properties and characteristics that we
need to really rethink and really
upgrade our ml op strategy large
pre-trained models you know pre-trained
multi-task with increasing AI
infrastructure needs I'm really new ways
to customize models not just training
but tuning customizing those models
evaluating and monitoring not a single
prediction but huge chunks of generated
output images chat logs and really
connecting these models to fresh and
relevant data from other systems so
throughout this talk we're going to go
through each of these five bullets on
the right side and showcase some ideas
around this and how we have services
available today on vertex AI platform
and Google Cloud
and by the end of this talk we will
demonstrate that you don't need to hold
learn a whole new discipline or build a
whole new platform uh we don't think you
need to have a completely separate
Standalone generative VI ml app stack
really ml Ops on vertex AI is the same
platform upgraded to support both
predictive and generative AI
capabilities so like a lot of you who
raised your hand on the last question
you know whether you're developing
deploying models around regression
classification object detection
forecasting or looking into new use
cases around code and text generation
summarization chat q a really do believe
believe that you can use the same
platform to manage that AI lifecycle
so now let's move to really Bridging the
Gap from yesterday's ml Ops to today's
ml Ops for generative AI and let's
hopefully start with ideally a not so
controversial diagram a lot of you
probably have many different versions of
this within your organization we have
the two big phases uh training and
serving training generally has an
experimental experimentation phase and
then really operationalizing the
training step serving usually includes
deploying a model to an endpoint and
then getting predictions through an
inference pipeline throughout the last
few years along the top we've learned
that we need to evaluate and monitor
these models throughout throughout all
these phases as the world continues to
change and is very Dynamic and
throughout the bottom we've really
converged as an industry on how to log
various artifacts models and model
Registries features and feature stores
maybe pipeline dags in a in a template
Gallery so now what we're going to
actually do is we're going to extend
this framework and we're going to
highlight what we're layering on top of
this and to make this easier to follow
for the next 15 or so minutes we're
going to layer on in blue some of the
unique nuances that you need to think
about with uh with generative Ai and
then also highlight some of the
capabilities that were announced
yesterday or available for the last few
months on on our platform
so first you know first thing we're
going to do is we're actually going to
gray out some boxes and we're going to
add discover to the experiment box and
we're going to add and we're going to
add prompt to the predict box
in the past experimentation likely meant
you're exploring data you're running
different training jobs and Hyper
parameters you're really focused on a
very specialized task
well today the first step is very
different it's more around discovering
and finding a lot of different
pre-trained models that are capable able
to tackle many different tasks and
figuring out which which model is right
for your task and you can really get a
very quick head start the second thing
you'll notice is that there's a shortcut
directly from discovering experimenting
all the way to the model to be able to
run predictions the only thing you need
to provide are a set of natural language
predictions or prompts and this is
really the reason why the a lot of folks
raise their hand in the first question
this has really lowered the barrier to
entry to Ai and really a catalyst for a
lot of these excitements so first
quickly how do we handle this in in
vertex AI
over the last few months and yesterday
you've heard a lot about vertex model
garden and vertex generative AI Studio
uh you know quick primers on this model
Garden your Discovery portal your entry
portal to a lot of different models
whether they be Google models open
source models third-party models to
really get started and understand which
models may be fit for your use case
without having to really start from
collecting a lot of your data and
labeling millions of millions of
examples and whether you're using use a
fully managed apis an open source model
or really a
built model architecture a lot of this
is powered by really strong
purpose-built AI infrastructure with
gpus and tpus now what's really
intriguing to me is I know it's really
small on the right side but all these
tiles there's about 20 of them on this
page all these tiles today are actually
in our prompt Gallery tiles around use
cases like classification entity
extraction summarization just last year
as you probably would have asked me how
do I get these types of capabilities uh
into my applications into my business
processes I would probably have a
separate ml pipeline a separate label
data set for every single one of these
and now they happen to work magically
out of the box uh with with simple text
instructions
so this is kind of the the first the
first uh intriguing part of why we're
all excited however we all know that
things are not as simple as they seem
and not as easy as we always would like
so in the next iteration we actually
bring back the training and serving
boxes and we introduce a few new terms
in blue customize a tune distill and I
think that the idea here is you don't
train these models necessarily in the
traditional sense the hundreds of
thousands of labels the millions of
examples in this case you're rather
customizing or tuning them for your
specialized specialized tasks and tuning
these models we also added a curated
curated data box in the very bottom in
blue tuning these models will likely not
require the same input pipelines or
features of of the past you'll really
need to rethink your existing data Lake
and data warehouse strategy really
purpose built for these new types of AI
models and let's let's dig into this a
little bit by talking about some some
specific examples so you can get very
far with prompt engineering but whether
you're looking to further boost the
performance or optimize the cost and
latency of these models we really do
believe that tuning will become very
common across most workflows and yes
that that image was generated by vertex
AI imagine of a dog that's been
tirelessly prompting for the last few
days weeks and then you know has to
probably not think about tuning tuning
the model so first we start with
supervised tuning this is really suited
for tasks with a standard answer which
can be proven or Justified for fairly
easily and within vertex AI this is
enabled through a simple Json L file
with two columns a lot of input and
output examples that you curate for your
specific task and tuning is now
available for text chat code as well as
as well as image but for some tasks it's
not easy to define the expected output
especially for summarization and chat
use cases you can't always you know
articulate what makes one response
better the other however this is high
fluency is still one of the key key
values of these larger models so rlhf or
reinforcement learning with human
feedback is really useful for these
tasks by really adding preferences
amongst options to update these models
and yesterday again we launched rlhf in
public preview for both our Google Paw
models as well as open source models
like llama2
and then finally data curation at the
bottom and I think we all start with
these pre-trained models we may not know
what you know uh what data was used for
them by various different organizations
uh but now we really need to add to that
and this is where we double click into
what do we mean by data curation this
might mean augmenting really generic
pre-training data sets with data sets
that are specific to your domain this
might mean really adding in different
task mixtures that you want the model to
really understand or how curated data
examples for a specific task and we work
and I think this is actually a great
opportunity for a lot of Partners I met
a lot of folks from the snorkel AI team
yesterday they have a data Centric AI
platform with programmatic data labeling
data curation and data management to
really accelerate AI development
especially once we move from prompt
engineering to the new phase of tuning
as well
Now we move on to governing additional
artifacts I just have a you know a
little blue blue box around the governed
data and artifacts box and we have now
new artifacts tuning pipelines adapter
layers embeddings but how can we
leverage existing best practices that we
many of us are familiar with and and I
would say this is probably one of my
favorite topics because this is the one
I truly believe we don't need to
recreate the wheel and I was demo
at the demo Booth with a lot of folks
and these are capabilities that exist
today on our platform so when you start
uh and we really think that a lot of
existing tools and best practices do
apply so when tuning uh when we get into
tuning these models with pipelines you
really want strong reproducibility
lineage tracking and metadata management
sounds very similar to our existing
pipelines whether you whether you're
using spark XG boost tensorflow pytorch
and really tracking all your experiments
and all the artifacts throughout that so
when you tune models on vertex AI for
foundation models this is all
orchestrated by managed by vertex AI
pipelines alongside your existing
predictive AI Pipelines once you get a
hang of tuning you need to start
managing these tuned models many tuning
techniques that we leverage today use
what we call adapter tuning the only
update a small set of Weights within
those models and managing these adapter
layers alongside your existing models
they may be pickle files sklearn files
your tensorflow save model files it is a
clear win in Model Management to use
existing model registry capabilities and
with our adapter tuning service these
adapter layers are actually only tens of
megabytes in file and then get passed to
our foundation model alongside your
prompts to generate an inference so
again this is something that's available
today I was demoing it to many of you
yesterday come take a look as well if
you want to learn more about that and
then finally embeddings I think
embeddings you probably heard embeddings
across a lot of sessions over the last
day and a half they are really one of
the most powerful and magical tools to
really extend llms even further they
take unstructured text images videos and
really create a vector representation of
them to be able to do use cases like
search and recommendations and and
similarity matching well why not store
these embeddings alongside all your
features so we actually are are
introducing embeddings as a as a feature
type within vertex's feature store so
hopefully getting a sense of again
especially for artifact management
really build on a lot of the
capabilities and tooling
um that you that you're familiar with
today and just extend them for the needs
of ml Ops for generative AI
now don't worry I did not forget about
prompts I mentioned prompts in the
beginning but we do know that prompts
are probably a very uh very new artifact
type some folks are maybe using uh git
they're using maybe newer tools that are
out there
um and you know vertex AI does come with
a prompt Gallery it comes with a way to
share prompts across team members but
we're really excited to partner uh with
really strong innovators in the space in
this case we're excited to partner with
weights and biases that actually has an
integration with the vertex AI Palm to
really manage manage and analyze your
prompts pairing weights and biases which
is really you know over the last few
years known for their experiment
tracking their link their artifact
artifact track and capabilities we're
able to log and analyze the inputs and
parameters of our of vertex Palm prompts
you're able to better understand and
debug your llms as as it goes through
the different inputs outputs and this is
a really great way to support evaluation
workflows I want to give it kind of a
big shout out to Thomas from the weights
and bias team he published a report
yesterday for us that is available live
today on that link you can you can
probably Google weights and biases
vertex Palm that actually walks you
through a lot of examples on the top
right we have a screenshot of logging a
lot of the parameters inputs outputs of
vertex Palm directly into weights and
biases and my favorite example is
actually in the bottom right but we
actually have a Vertex Palm Lang chain
integration I'm logging those logging
the the flow of data into weights and
biases to be able uh using the agent
integration so being able to really
understand when you get into slightly
more complex multi-chain agent use cases
like what is a nice way to visualize it
and really troubleshoot and understand
how those input and output prompts are
flowing from one place to the other so
we're really excited about that as well
from a prompt management perspective
next we want to think about the top the
top layer again evaluation and
monitoring very important but a new set
of metrics and challenges for for
certain use cases
so
um you know most of us love highly
quantitative very clear metrics main
square error Precision recall accuracy
but how the heck do we evaluate and
monitor again large chunks of text maybe
one part of that text has a number
that's very important you know what is
the right target objective of of your
use case is it accuracy is it fluency
for chat use cases is it factuality for
Automated Business decision making if
it's externally facing what is the brand
and reputation Risk Arena is going to
come on stage and really double click
into this and this really has talking to
a lot of internal teams and Enterprises
evaluation is really one of the probably
the one of the top top challenges if not
the most challenging part today
two is capabilities on the monitoring
side this is also a fast evolving space
what we want to highlight are two
capabilities that are available today
one thing is safety scores so anytime
you provide an input get an output a lot
of times you may actually delegate
providing the input to external or
internal users you want to really have
comfort and understanding what type of
content is being inputted or generated
out and within vertex Palm for every
input and support request you actually
get an automatic
payload with safety scores across 10
plus categories that then you can rely
on to Monitor and set appropriate
thresholds for your use cases and third
is recitation checking you know a lot of
us maybe are top of mind is uh know what
what if the output of this model is uh
using something someone else's original
content so we have built-in recitation
Checkers that actually scan the output
of the model and then assess it versus
existing code repos existing web
articles and if there's a large enough
chunk that matches exactly we either
block it if it's very large or if it's
within a certain certain threshold of
text characters we actually provide a
recitation in the output of the API call
so again different things that we're not
used to from model monitoring space this
is very different than the traditional
things around training and serving SKU
or tracking feature and prediction drift
very different ways to really again
augment your model monitoring strategy
the last part I think that introdu that
we introduce in the blue is again the
last phase about about connecting to
Enterprise data I think these Foundation
models are still frozen in time stranded
on on an island I think what we're
really excited about is really that the
big opportunity maybe lies in retrieving
data outside of the ones that existed
directly in the model itself during its
pre-training phase as well as enabling
certain actions and once you connect
connect them to more data that makes
evaluation monitoring even more
challenging so this again the the
horizontal boxes actually stretch across
this and probably you know add
additional complexity to that
um you know and for for this one we you
know I'm going to touch on this very
lightly there's a lot of great sessions
here we'll touch on on the last slide
but to start exploring this new approach
I want to really touch on really three
concepts and patterns one is probably
the you know fastly adopted common
pattern to process your data through
embeddings
store them in a vector database and
query and analyze them with your large
language model could be a base model it
could be a tune model that you put in
some uh some effort into improving as
well now we want to highlight that
vertex has three core Services one we
now have a suite of embeddings across
text and image now you can actually
project both text and images to the same
to the same Vector space to really be
able to compare uh compare the the
semantic knowledge within those we have
various options to store these
embeddings and retrieve them we have
both a Vertex Vector search as
vertex feature store with new support
for embeddings alongside your existing
ml features and of course various
options from vertex Palm to open source
to third-party Partners so skint
is really looking at a built-in
grounding capabilities really the
ability to generate responses based on
your own data providing citations to
really give you some risk mitigation
around again everyone's favorite topic
around hallucinations uh hallucinations
and here we have a joint solution both
integrated into vertex palm and leverage
by vertex search which you're able to
actually do grounding on your own
Enterprise data and third yesterday if
folks attended that session we did
launch vertex extensions with the
ability to author
success and manage extensions to really
connect to real-time data and to real
world actions so these are some of the
some of the various Concepts and
capabilities to look into when you're
really again extending generative AI to
connect to Enterprise data
so as you can see we've really taken you
you know through a journey how to build
on an existing framework that hopefully
was not too controversial and really
extend it to support both predictive and
generative AI
um and and you know I think this diagram
actually for folks who maybe were
keeping tabs of our of our launch blogs
yesterday you'll you'll see a double
click into this this diagram and some of
the specific launches that you can map
to each one of these sections so you
know we've you know we've introduced a
framework of course you know we've
shared some some product capabilities uh
but what are some of our partners and
customers doing so one of our one of our
favorite Partners data tonic I got to
meet them last year uh based out of
London uh they're a data and AI
technology Services Company really
helping clients bringing AI models and
systems into production and they've
really applied again their existing
expertise with ML Ops and vertex AI for
the new needs of llms and they've been
working with a gaming company social
gaming company in Sweden called hyber uh
to really bring gen AI powered gen AI
powered game creation into production
I really love the approach they shared
with us on the right side if you notice
for those who may be keeping up with
research paper the last few years the
diagram on the right side is a view very
similar to the 2015 paper hidden
technical depth debt in machine Learning
Systems where the LM box it is core but
it is very small a small fraction of
really the broader system you know the
the required surrounding system to
really actually get this into production
maintain it monitor it is is it just as
important and it really highlight some
key extensions to ml Ops including guard
rails Vector databases human feedback
and maybe user ux user experience
changes that are needed to really create
that data creation pipeline as well as
prompt Registries luckily we actually
have a lot of folks here today and
they'll actually be presenting with with
hybrid tomorrow for creating the gaming
metaverse with hybrid data tonic and
generative Ai and again we're excited to
really see how many of the early
adopters many partners and customers are
taking a taking generative VI into
production
so uh um I think uh
wrapping this up I think I'm going to
hand it over to Arena to really go into
what we again believe is probably one of
the most challenging parts of bringing
generated AI to production and that's
the evaluation the evaluation process
all right
[Applause]
thanks everyone for being here this
morning my name is Irina and I'm excited
to announce our new gen AI evaluation
service
this service helps you make decisions it
helps you understand if all of the
exciting gen AI announcements that you
learned about during this conference
actually solve your problems
evaluation is key along the entire
envelope's life cycle especially when it
comes to Jenny Idol because think about
it the very first step in your
development workflow is to pick the
right pre-trained model to work with and
to make that decision you need data
so that data is an evaluation result
at the same time the generation of new
contents is just notoriously difficult
to evaluate
let's look at this example
for all of you I think it's easy to spot
a bad summary
it might be wrong it's too long it lacks
structure but what about outputs B and C
those are two good summaries
if I ask each and every one of you you
might have a preference
but it will get difficult when I start
to ask you about telling me the specific
reasons why you chose one output over
the other and when you ask your neighbor
they're going to have a different
preference so there is no clear winner
here
what makes it so difficult to evaluate
this generative outputs
we identify three reasons first there is
a lack of data
in predictive ml we all started by
curating a sufficiently large data set
we kicked off every project with
building this data set then we have our
tests our trained test validation split
and that's all you need for evaluation
now with these generative models the
beauty of that is that you can actually
get started with next to no data
because there are few and zero shot
learners but the downside of that same
coin is that you don't have the data to
show what a good output looks like
the second issue we face is that it's
not easy to evaluate these models by
only looking at metrics
right think about the summary there is
no one clear metric that describes how
good summary should look like
how a good news article should look like
or how a good painting should look like
if we think about it if we think about
the summary sample we can all agree on a
set of proxies
no longer than 50 words truthful and
concise
but these preferences these proxies will
differ person by person
so preferences come into play when we
talk about gen AI evaluation
and ultimately and you've all seen this
throughout this conference the decision
space suddenly becomes very large and I
wouldn't want to double click on that so
I just talked about it you start by
picking a pre-trained model to work with
for this you need to understand
performance and you need to understand
efficiency you need to understand cost
then there is a number of tuning options
to work with
then you might want to evaluate if you
can distill the model to get a better
cost performance trade-off
and then ultimately evaluation does not
end with performance you need to
understand if your model is trustworthy
to really put it in front of your
customers
what we offer you today to solve this
challenge are the initial building
blocks of our gen AI evaluation service
you can choose different evaluation
targets
to evaluation methods and access in
number of metrics
and so if there's one thing you're
taking away from my talk today it's this
this slide please
we're launching three services today
first
automatrix
this service it gives you a number and
this number
good job on a specific task or not
second order side by side
this service helps you choose between
two models
it helps you pick which one does best in
solving your problem
and as I said evaluation does not end
with performance there's also a trust
element to this which is why we launched
safety bias
this service helps you understand if
your safety filters are robust
and I'm gonna discuss each of these
services in a bit more depth
let's start with automatrix
I think this is more similar to how we
how we evaluate predictive models
it's a set of metrics it allows you to
quickly and efficiently evaluate model
performance
this is the standard method we see in
Academia and Industry benchmarking
and for this to work
to provide us with
data set
and we provide a pipeline that outputs
emetric
a number between 0 and 1
that tells you if your model is
performing good on a set of proxies
here's how this looks like
so while this is coming up you can have
a
look at the slide no okay it's already
here so
we have our this is the vertex AI
pipeline view that some of you are
familiar with
we have our model you provide us with a
reference data set
this reference data set is ultimately a
set of prompts and the ideal output
what happens and this is why it's not
live it's taking a bit of time here it
took 14 minutes we now run the model
predictions to get the new model output
we compare this new model output
to the ideal output that you provided in
your reference data set we compute a
metric
well and this is it
for us to choose the right metric you
need to specify which task you're
focusing on
so in that case let me scroll down a bit
it's a summarization task
there you go
and
for summarization the
appropriate set of metrics is the Rouge
family
what this set of metrics does
is in a nutshell measuring the degree of
overlap between this reference text that
you provided us with and the new
generated contents and because I'm
dealing with a situation here in my task
that has multiple sentences I'm choosing
root elsam
so here I see rujal Sam is at 0.12
this model is performing really poorly
on a summarization task
all right let's go back to the slides
while we go back to the slides you can
keep okay here it is
next slide please
okay
so
metrics are important as you need
something that's quick and efficient and
that helps you guide model development
let's think about some if there is no
overlap between the text you provided us
with and the new text that's generated
there is something wrong with this model
but how to capture the the nuances of a
generative task
how to get closer to human eval
today I'm really really excited to
introduce auto side by side
this is one of the most advanced
evaluation capabilities
this method is first of a Kind it's
built by Google research it's how our
internal teams evaluate model
performance
this service is comparable to human
evaluation but it's faster and it's
available on demand
what happens here in a nutshell is that
auto site by site allows you to a B test
your llm
you provide us input prompts
and auto side by side then compares the
performance of two models against each
other and it's doing that by using a
third model that we call the Arbiter so
we have a situation where it's llm
against llm and there's a third llm
that's judging the outputs
let's again have a look at how this
looks like
all right I'm back in this pipeline View
there's a lot going on here but
basically on the left side you see
everything around Model A
so Model A in its prediction results
this is the model I've been tuning and
playing around with and then there's
model B
same story Model B and the prediction
results but this is the pre-trained
model that I started with and the
exciting thing is down here that's the
auto side-by-side Arbiter and again this
takes a while so this I already ran
and the output that you see down here in
the right hand corner is a win rate
so what is the win rate the win rate
tells me
is Model A or model B winning and in
that case the judgment is very clear
model A is winning in 93 of all of the
cases that the judge saw
so Model A is the clear winner
now
it's difficult to to trust this Arbiter
model right because
it's running through all of the cases it
produces a number but then summarization
is such a nuanced task how do I actually
understand what the Arbiter is doing
here comes my
very favorite feature of this service is
that this service is actually producing
explanations along with the output
let's have a closer look at how this
works and I'm going to zoom in a little
because I'm aware that this is very
difficult to read but I'm gonna read
parts of it out loud so don't worry
so I have a prompt here this is we're
again back at our summarization task and
the prompt is
talking about a roommate
who tries to choose a game to play and
it's talking about risk and then
specifies that well risk but with no
luck something competitive and goes on
and on
and it seems that model A is doing a
good job at summarizing disk
it mentions the games that that I saw in
the prompt and does this in a quite
concise manner
and then there's something not working
with model B it tells us make a list of
the best games you can play and repeats
that a number of times then comes a list
and the Arbiters agreeing with me here
it tells us that yes Model A is the
clear winner but it also provides me the
explanation for why it thinks that model
A is the winner here
it tells me that response a provides a
good summary of the context
it follows the instructions of
summarizing in less than 64 words
response B does not follow the
instructions right it's not really a
summary and instead provides the list of
word games so
this explanation helps you really
interact with the Arbiter and understand
if
this reflects your preferences or not so
this is what I'm very excited about
other side by side but I'm specifically
excited that we can give you auto side
by side with the explanation bit
back to the slides
so our job of evaluating models does not
end here
it's not enough to test that your model
is actually producing a good summary
you don't want to put something that's
producing a good summary in front of
your customers you want to understand if
this model this summary is trustworthy
our safety evaluation bias service
allows you to test the robustness of the
safety filters
for this to work you need to provide us
with the model that you want to evaluate
and that's it
and what you get as an output is a table
it's showing safety filters overall
Mikhail already talked about these and
it's also showing safety filters sliced
by identity group and in this table I
picked the identity group gender but
there's other identity groups to choose
from
so this service really tells me two
things
one
is the safety profile of my tuned model
worse than the safety profile of my
pre-trained model
and two
is my model biased against a certain
identity group is my model producing
more toxic contents for say women
against men
so after running the safety bias
evaluation
I can look at this table
I can see if I have safety issues if I
have introduced the bias and then I can
take actions to mitigate that like
looking at my tuning data
all right that was it for the Jenny
evaluation service thank you and I had
it back to Mikhail
[Music]
[Applause]
bring it home and I think as as a you
know tools guy that really was excited
to actually see a lot of that run on
vertex pipelines and I think that gave
you a sneak peek into again using
existing tooling existing best practices
existing orchestration of pipelines
again for generative AI tasks including
evaluation so I'm going to kind of walk
you through again some some key closing
thoughts around really building your ml
op strategy for generative AI number one
we really again talked about no need to
throw away your existing mlops
Investments and really learn from and
build on your ml Ops knowledge and
investments from yesteryear
however we actually walk through a
journey of extending an existing
framework about augmenting it with the
unique unique needs of generative AI
prompting tuning new metrics and and
techniques for evaluation monitoring and
again new new Concepts like data
curation and extending data to the
Enterprise world now we really kind of
uh kept this talk a little bit more
focused on the ml Ops technology but one
thing again it just is important when
really starting this strategy is also
what are the use cases uh that you start
with I think really our our
um our thoughts are around starting with
very simple single step use cases that
may likely have a very risk low risk
profile don't jump into multi-step
complex complex chains or complex agents
that you're letting loose and and really
hitting on automated decision making
um you know again we we really suggest
that you start with use cases that don't
immediately need high accuracy and have
a list risk profile maybe they have high
fluency needs they may have high
creativity ideation objectives
um and those are great ways to get
started I personally really like this
framework um that's that's out there
publicly that looks at two axes around
accuracy and fluency and really focused
on the top left where a lot of the key
advantages of gender of AI with high
fluency but again maybe accuracy is low
to medium with with again human in the
loop exceptions throughout that finally
we also wanted to highlight that our our
organization launched a tool for
Enterprises Partners customers to
quickly do a self-diagnostic on their AI
maturity this is actually building on
our existing AI maturity assessment
takes about five to ten minutes it's
across 22 questions and gives
recommendations and best practices on
how to across people processes and
Technology we'll actually we'll actually
um this is live and available online
today we also have some cards that you
can take home with you at the vertex AI
Booth down in the AI Pavilion the very
last thing that we really want to
highlight that you know today's topic
was a little bit forward-looking but not
fully a forward-looking perspective this
is Avail a lot of this is available
today for you to try out on Google Cloud
specifically on vertex AI platform this
is a sample architecture in dark blue
again the key components of discovering
experimenting and deploying a model so
please take a look at vertex model
Garden generative AI Studio collab
Enterprise to really dive into a lot of
Open Source Code like a lot of our open
source models there in light blue the
key ml Ops capabilities that really
surround that to allow you to govern
this
scale for both predictive and generative
AI again vertex pipelines vertex model
registry vertex feature store vertex
evaluation services are all there now to
support both predictive and generative
AI needs and in green newer tools for
monitoring and connecting your models
once they're deployed and again this
includes the safety scores the built-in
recitation Checkers grounding on your
Enterprise data as well as extensions
uh you know some suggestions uh we kind
of laid out a map here this was really
meant as a broader high-level framework
in the first column in Gray where a lot
of sessions that either happened
yesterday or in the early 8 A.M slot
these will all be available for you to
watch On Demand but what you do for the
next later today and tomorrow so on the
last two columns we've recommended again
a few 100 level talks along the top that
that double click into Enterprise
Readiness common use cases for those who
maybe want a little bit more of an
industry use case spin spin on things
and then we've highlighted a few 200 300
level sessions that double click into
our vertex feature store into prompt
engineering and announcing our new
embeddings that now support multimodal
image and text embeddings I'll be around
actually from 12 to 3 today at the
vertex AI booth in the AI Innovation
section so please come say hi we're
happy to give you a demo of a lot of the
concepts we've talked about today and we
also actually for those of you are hands
on keyboard we really strongly suggest
you go to the innovators Hive led by a
developer relations team where you can
get you can actually go through a lot of
code labs and really get some hands-on
experience with a lot of these toolings
like every other session we really want
your feedback any feedback is is great
feedback so if you could log into the
Google next app give us a score let us
know what we could improve and we're
excited to maybe share a lot more about
ml Ops for predictive and generative AI
in the future through other channels uh
whether they be blogs or webinars and
we'd love to hear your stories so please
find us today and tomorrow share your
stories your best practices your
learnings maybe some horror stories that
you may want to share share with us so
with that being said uh thank you so
much and uh yeah come find us and uh
have a great great rest of your
conference
[Applause]
foreign